lightning strikes above the highest
tower of the imposing medieval castle
standing Atop The Hill in front of you
the surrounding landscape Beneath The
Fortress is a dark Forest just perfect
for hiding Untold numbers of dangers
you're not exactly sure where you are or
why you were brought here but you never
do it doesn't matter though you'll
figure it all out in due time you always
do the context of why you're brought to
the places you need to be is never
important in fact you don't pay it any
mind at all all that matters is that you
help the people who need it the most
save them from the terror that seems to
creep around every corner no matter
where you wind up it's always a struggle
these people seem bent on doing
everything in ways that seem to always
put them in the most danger the world
seems to Revel in that danger sometime
comes out smarting and coming up with
new ways to hurt and terrify those who
you try to help but it doesn't matter
you're a hero in fact with how many new
places and settings you've seen to
instantaneously crop up in you seem to
be the hero that's always how you've
been you hop from one location to the
next the days bleeding into one another
never needing rest you're not even sure
who you are in a traditional sense you
don't know your name your appearance is
vague and fuzzy your Humanity itself is
even debatable but you don't care about
any of that deep inside you there's a
drive a drive to help others and save
them from the cruelness and horrors of
the situations they find themselves in
you can never pin it down but nothing
ever feels right in the places you crop
up things just seem to work against
these folks as much as they can cars
don't start while knife brandishing
Killers pursue them from the woods
Undead zombies always seem to know where
others are hiding ghosts and monsters
know the exact ways to terrify and scare
their victims ordinary kind people
always seem to find themselves in the
most unexplainable unfortunate
situations caught up in Tales of the
supernatural of the Arcane and of
absolute Terror it's like the universe
is working against them putting them in
these situations on purpose almost for
entertainment purposes but you're
smarter than that and you have been for
as long as you've been doing this which
is a very very long time jumping from
one location to the next contending with
Paranormal Activity and Supernatural
foes saving would-be victims from their
clutches you understand that this is
your purpose you understand that you are
a hero and that's all you need to know
you've picked up quite the skill set and
contextual savviness over the thousands
of times you've done this don't go down
that Alleyway don't split up from a
group and don't leave the house or some
of the most common platitudes you have
to tell the people you meet on your
Journeys they seem obvious enough but
most of the time they don't listen they
go on vacation against your wishes and
then they find themselves in a haunted
hotel room they send their kids to a
summer camp only to find that it's been
stalked by a brutalizing slasher they
move into a house with a history of
being haunted and are somehow surprised
when the spirits don't take kindly to
their new guests to you it all seems so
obvious you've seen it all before that
it's predictable but for others they
have a serious difficulty understanding
that their lives are in imminent danger
for some reason it's like they're
predisposed to doing the exact opposite
of what you tell them to do but it's no
matter whatever they wind up doing
you'll be there to stop the horrific
paranormal threats that continuously
endanger their lives after all you're
the hero and so you set off moving
towards the castle and the distance
you're not sure of what you're supposed
to do yet but you'll figure it out after
a half hour of trekking in the dark
Misty Woods you come across a broken
down old school car stuck in a massive
ditch inside is a young couple dressed
in older clothing
they seem to be elated at your arrival
thanking you before you've even done
anything you asked them what happened
and they explained that while driving
they got lost and somehow found
themselves in this Forest the fog was so
thick the man explained that he lost
control of the vehicle entirely and
found himself in a ditch you scratch
your chin like most situations you've
come across you've seen it before a
young couple forced to take refuge in a
dangerous location after their vehicle
broke down and if you were a betting man
you'd wager everything you'd own that
the dangerous location in question is
none other than that creepy Castle on
the hilltop you assist the couple and
try to help them push their car out of
the ditch you ask what their plan is and
of course they tell you that they're
planning on seeing if they can spend the
night in the castle you shake your head
wanting to tell them that it's a bad
idea but if you come out of the gate
with a warning it's going to raise
questions now your day saving has to be
as natural as possible at least when you
can help it with some effort you manage
to free the car from the ditch setting
it on the dirt road once more a couple
thanks you but just as they're about to
start the car again a loud Spark from
underneath the hood makes a loud pop in
the Silent Night air of course the
universe is doing everything it can to
get this helpless couple into that
castle after some deliberation you
decide to hold off on telling them to
stay away from the castle no reasonable
person is going to want to stay the
night in an unfamiliar forest and given
the time period you found yourself in
it's not like you can call for help
besides if you stay out here any longer
and delay going into the castle who
knows what else the universe will throw
at you maybe you'll be attacked by
Wolves or crushed under a conveniently
falling tree the castle might be their
best option for short-term safety but
it's almost certainly packed with
dangers of its own design you tell the
couple that you'll watch their car and
that you'll follow them shortly maybe
you can fix it or figure out what's
wrong in your travels you've picked up
some rudimentary automobile knowledge
now it's time to put it to the test
after a cautious goodbye you watch the
two walk the Steep Hill to the imposing
Stone Castle and knock on the large
wooden doors with a timid push of the
metal gargoyle door knocker now that
they're gone you can work your magic you
wait until you see the couple greeted by
a woman with black hair and a red dress
who welcomes them into the foyer with a
concerningly devilish laugh they're all
so gullible you think to yourself but it
doesn't matter you have a job to do
throughout the night you scope out the
castle snaking around the outside
peering in Windows and traversing hidden
passageways you're pretty sure you're
unseen the whole time even by the
numerous guard dogs and strange giant
bat creatures that Patrol the premises
funny how that works when you want to be
perceived you have no difficulty being
noticed but when you want to be hidden
it's like no one can notice you while
the universe may work against you in so
many ways it's also blessed you with a
variety of benefits and lucky breaks
after all you are the hero of this story
and of every story you find yourself
within you've determined through your
impeccably stealthy sneaking skills that
this Castle belongs to none other than
the vampire Countess lady brunhildhas an
immortal creature who feasts on the
blood of humans and lives out her days
in a creepy cobweb infested Castle a by
the books vampire through and through
you've contended with so many of them at
this point they're trivial heck you've
saved hundreds of people from the
infamous Count Dracula the deadliest and
most famous vampire of them all multiple
times across multiple Worlds by now you
know all the tricks a stake through the
heart a silver bullet sunlight garlic
fire holy water now that you think about
it vampires are pretty vulnerable
creatures and if it weren't for their
deceptive nature quick thinking magical
powers and Hyper fast reflexes it'd be
hard for anyone to find them scary now
understanding your target It's Time To
Play Your Part as the hero Vanquish this
monster and save that couple just as the
Countess is planning to sneak into the
guest bedroom where the couple is
sleeping and sink her fangs into their
necks you leap from the Shadows with the
wooden stake you found inside the
Castle's catacombs and hit her in the
head with as much force as possible it's
not enough and the Countess lunges
forward screeching the couple jolts
awake just in time to witness the
Countess and you duking it out in the
guest bedroom seeing a vulnerable spot
the Countess transforms into a bat and
flies toward the girl to attack but the
Countess got greedy because
unfortunately for her she couldn't
predict that she was within throwing
distance of the stake you picked up you
hurl It Forward Precision striking the
transform Countess right in the wing
injured she changes back into her human
form giving you enough time to pull the
stake from what was her wing and now her
bloody arm and drive it straight through
her heart and seal her fate forever it's
not pretty and now you're covered in
vampire blood but you got the job done
the couple is shocked but they both saw
it with their own eyes the Countess was
a vampire she transformed into a bat and
they need to get out of there you guide
them through the castle narrowly
avoiding the locations of all the garden
creatures and into a room containing the
countess's horse-drawn carriage you set
them off on their way just as the sun
rises and remind them to not forget the
luggage in the back of their car that's
still in the woods you feel a sense of
satisfaction as you always do after your
quests but as soon as that feeling
washes over you you're whisked away to a
different location but this time
something is different you blink and you
wind up in what appears to be a facility
you've been to some place similar before
but nothing like this it's massive
filled with dozens upon dozens of people
rushing from way to hallway and in those
hallways are doors oh so many doors you
scratch your head but the confusion
disappears as you grab a young man in an
orange jumpsuit by the shoulders and
inform him that he's about to be
terminated due to misconduct in a
research environment you're not even
sure what that means but the words come
out of you like they're preordained it
felt like the right thing to say and
you're not exactly wrong the man pushes
your hand away swearing at you before
moving forward presumably to his death
four armed guards approach you from the
distance and before you know it you're
taken to a room with two-way glass a
microphone and a strange device strapped
around your neck called by one of the
lab coats as a Scranton reality anchor
whatever that means they've given you a
name
scp-2786 and from what you can glean
they know quite a bit about you a suited
individual sits down across the two-way
glass and begins asking you questions
you don't have time for this you have
business elsewhere you explain to the
agent as he calls himself that you're a
hero who goes from place to place
wherever you're called upon those in
distress those suffering your their
Champion the agent asks why they found
you inside horror movies and books and
you're taken aback books movies what is
he talking about you explain that your
work is very real and that before the
incident with the Vampire you just
finished dispatching of a hockey mask
wearing slasher at Camp Crystal Lake and
saving a group of teenagers it was easy
work for you of course it was just one
guy and those kids ignored all of the
obvious warning signs the agent confirms
that he saw you do that and you're even
more confused he was there the agent
catches himself and explains that while
he wasn't exactly there he watched it
play out in the movie he tries to
explain that all of your adventures are
taking place in fictional locations
movies books you
scp-2786 enter these mediums through
mysterious unknown means and alter their
plots entirely copies of films and books
that you enter are changed and the
characters always manage to escape the
horror of the film due to your
assistance you alter stories early
changing them entirely movies books this
is not only ridiculous but it's also
getting on your nerves the agent is
wasting your time and you have to go
save those guys in the orange jumpsuits
from being terminated or reassigned or
whatever it is you stand up and the
anchor device somehow turns itself off
and attaches from your neck you face
through the wall on your left unsure
exactly of how you did it but felt
natural maybe that's how this world
Works certain people can do things like
this and these guys are trying to
contain them like a government
organization or the Men in Black your
genre savviness pays off yet again
whatever this SCP Foundation is you've
read them like an open book and now that
you understand the situation you can do
what you were sent here to do you hear
the sound of an alarm in the distance
but you can't be stopped over the next
few hours you break into multiple
containment cells freeing orange
jumpsuits or d-class personnel as
they're called by the foundation as well
as several other kind regular people who
just happen to have anomalous abilities
contained within the site these
Foundation types disgust you thinking
they can lock up human lives without
regard for their rights or dignity
studying them you bet they want to study
you too but they're not going to as soon
as you feel your work is done you're
whisked away to another location away
from the strange Foundation facility and
into an ordinary American city where you
assist a cast of characters in narrowly
avoiding the traps and Sinister games of
a killer puppet who wants to murder them
but after getting the job done this time
you're not taken anywhere new you're in
the same location over and over again on
a loop after the 48th time saving these
characters you start to consider what
the agent had told you you enter films
books horror stories your fictional well
meta fictional you exist inside the work
and out of it the prospects of this are
strange and new but if they're true it
might explain why you've never felt like
the people you save like you always felt
like you were in a story that you were
the only real person there if everyone
else is just a character what does that
make you alone
entirely if you're inside a movie right
now can someone be looping it playing
back the DVD over and over again to keep
you trapped there is it the foundation
is this how the foundation is going to
contain you now will you tell yourself
you are not going to be contained
another 30 Loops of the same monotonous
ordeal but then you're transported
somewhere new you laugh to yourself
having somehow escaped the Trap planted
by the foundation before you know it
you'll be off to a new story and you can
continue doing what you do best but as
the world Fades out around you it
doesn't seem to come back you seem to be
stuck in a sea of white and black and
red those same colors over and over
extending on forever you walk for what
seems to be ours and as you do
surroundings begin to form around you a
concrete wall a concrete floor a bed a
door leading to another Endless Sea of
white red and black and on the floor a
logo a circle within a circle with three
arrows pointing inwards for the first
time in your life you're unsure of what
you should be doing that logo it's the
logo of the SCP Foundation and you look
like you're inside a containment cell no
you pound against the wall collapsing it
and allowing the Sea of white swallow
you whole more logos more empty brackets
a file you're inside a file no a cell of
your own design you're creating the
containment cell your own brain however
it works is generating a narrative The
Narrative of you being contained by the
SCP Foundation a horror story and that's
exactly what the foundation used to trap
you you're not sure where you are nor
can you feel your body or even your
sense of self all that you know is that
you're trapped you've been whisked away
to a new story all right your story and
it seems to be harder and harder to
escape from but then the cell around you
collapsed once more and you found
yourself in a familiar setting a
medieval castle being urged by a queen
to slay a great evil you manage to
escape you don't know how you did it but
you're back to your old life jumping
from story to story you know all the
Beats all the cliches and all the right
things to do and for the next few hours
you do them slaying the great beast and
stealing his Divine amulet to bring back
to the kingdom but after the fact it
felt Hollow it didn't feel real not like
the other times you weren't sure how a
location could tell a lie but this one
felt as if its truth were paper thin
with someone pulling the strings and
making this world a lie for them like
true Mercury or an illusion and suddenly
just as you begin to suspect this
narrative to be another means of
containment generated by the foundation
everything goes back to that white
containment cell they can't keep you
here they can't keep you here you repeat
it over and over shouting it into the
distance you just want to go home you
beg they can't control you you're the
hero of this story if you're fictional
you're a good character you did
everything right you don't understand
this is your story and it will always be
your story the foundation is just
another one of the countless villains
you've fought those self-righteous
murderers you will surpass them you
shout into the void of Television static
and endless torment for what seems like
decades and
Tire of your yelling you realize one
thing this is eternal now go check out
scp-1230 a hero is born and scp-423
self-inserting character for more plot
twisters and story Hoppers from SCP
explained